Yes, stressful moments building a team,
there really are a lot.
And the biggest one for
me I remember is then, and honestly,
I still feel this today even in a larger
company when you get to hire somebody,
you've decided that you want
them to join the company.
It's that moment when you are waiting
for them to get back to you, because
once you've decided that somebody is
going to help you grow your company and
get you to the next step,
it feels like life or death to you.
And so you're just sitting there like,
please say yes, please say yes.
Texting them may be a little too much.
You know, it's almost like dating.
So yeah, it's a little stressful.